breaking right now first here at 11.
police investigating a deadly stabbing
right near unlv good evening everybody
i'm david charns metro police telling 8
news now an off-duty security guard took
this suspect into custody it's all
happening on maryland parkway right near
university road our sasha loftis is live
there with some new information tonight
sasha
david this investigation is still
underway hours after police say a man
was stabbed and killed at a bus stop
here are near a bus stop on maryland
parkway right in front of unlv now
police say it's important to note no
students were involved here officers
tell us two men were arguing on a bus
then got off at this bus stop and their
fight turned physical one stabbed the
other multiple times with a large knife
and killed him that's when a security
officer working for in and out burger
who was not armed ran over and took that
suspect into custody i asked officers
whether students should be concerned
they want to stress this was an isolated
situation
obviously a very disturbing scene when
you have somebody who is stabbed in
front of a
university but again
the suspect was taken into custody it is
an isolated incident in the sense that
it involved two non-students and
there was multiple police officers on
scene that quickly responded as soon as
the incident did occur
no word yet on whether these two men
knew each other police are still
investigating that now as for that
suspect he is now facing an open murder
charge you can see here back out here
live the road is closed on maryland
parkway north of tropicana again right
here in front of unlv and it should stay
closed for a little while longer as
police continue their investigation so
avoid the area if you can reporting live
tonight sasha loftis live local now